let me tell you about this is this idea
is first goodbye always your people are
going on
all right bye-bye heads up by Aussie
people and uh yeah a good season lobby
is 15 years down okay
a bear a few views in a person said you
before but most of you has not so let's
just underneath this lines give you a
really quick like what does this
definition for what this is and then
we'll act I'll show you an accident so
casually capture is a technique for
using samples that's why I ended ID here
use these samples to estimate a
population size so you can see wave
belongs
some people like why why bio invading my
math class okay this is what I belong to
because the objected about set Wars and
population okay so how do you do this or
or even why when you're trying to work
out a population size if you can do
something like a census then that's
great you have really your authority and
numbers you check everyone exactly one
is very double counting there's no
missing of people so you can use those
to get accurate numbers however that's
not always possible right particularly
when you're dealing with populations say
for example of large demand for wellness
fine okay so when you're dealing with
animals you can't just get them to line
up with a nice people I to make sure you
don't double count them and you make
sure is everyone here all the way I was
like present for overall you can't do
that okay so here's the luminol
batteries right as the name suggests you
go into this population you capture some
of them and then you must emit some
identifiable way release them back into
the wild
and then you recapture them and look at
how many people have been tagged did
that identifiable welcome so here's an
example
so you're trying to work out how many
fish are there in this leg how many fish
are there in this leg but a lake is a
mysterious place it's not - can't see
very far the dish don't exactly stand up
in the New Year I owe a number one so
what you do is you trawl your next
through you capture a hundred and twenty
of them you capture and you work out how
many there are and then you put a tag on
all okay so you've got 120 fish
they've all been labeled once you know
which piece they are because they
detained and how many there are
you release them back into the lid okay
you then come back like a few days later
or something like that and you recapture
like you still pull that this through
okay and you recapture a right so you've
done the first stage you captured and
tagged then you go back again you might
get the same time but officially you
might get less maybe it's like a you
know a warm day or something like that
and it just aren't many of them half
anymore you recapture eighty and you
notice that six of them had panicked now
this is all the information we need it's
in Jesus actually when you think about
okay what have you just determined from
this information what you showed is that
you knew there are a hundred hundred
twenty tags floating around in the
population and a hundred and twenty
they're just really dumb suppose there
were twelve thousand fish twelve
thousand fish in this population
what percentage of fish have the time
exactly one percent right that's how
many would be so therefore we can
recapture you ought to expense about one
percent of your fish have got tags on
them because what resent them having
I think I didn't throw their 12000 right
I don't know Clinton 2012 outed by the
120 out of a million or something like
that
right so this number down here the size
of the population I do agree what it is
so I'm going to use our directors before
address for when you don't know what it
number is I just don't want to work with
that mathematically this this not me see
whatever ends up being is the proportion
of fish with hands please leave is a--
that's really important that you
understand why I am putting this
fraction into play right if n I should
actually label that - that's the total
population if n works 5,000 like we
mentioned we know this was 1% I don't
know what it is so that's why I just
give it a label now this is what happens
when you did the capture then we
recapture and we again look and we see
well some of them have taggers some dope
okay
what percentage has text well there are
six but this time I knew a population
that I was looking at this is you know
subsection so six out of 18 have the
tags and this should be identical this
is still the proportion of fish McCabe
and total fish right does that make
sense so these proportions are equal on
different days of this week concern
we'll talk about that later in a second
you don't want to put tags on your [ __ ]
that becomes more likely or less likely
to be eaten because that will skew your
population and now what I need to do all
the way back like a.m. what an a.m. - so
just need to solve for n what will I do
I'm crustless one battle zone so 85:12
is like 812 so I'm having funny so
that's my peepees 9600 big and then if
you multiply both sides by n you get six
down over there okay I want to make and
the subject so what will I do besides
I'll divide by six which I'm pretty sure
leads me report doesn't okay now just
pause for a moment to assets check is
this what you expressing on a reasonable
number 1600 Fisher's awake
well we do I am told you anything at
this time to the lake why I'm just
looking these proportions to do not
match well this six out of eight less
than ten percent isn't it less than ten
percent under twenty is less than
success for sixteen open it if you go
ahead and gotcha questions you can
better your get exactly the same thing
thanks is that we're good you see how
sampling with you I just took a sample
and then I reset board and that can be
information about the whole population
so really smart way to do things okay